crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday
you already know though Orion's egg the
soccer star JUCO above-ground cool goes
better than most
Jay Larson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go again
father crab feast
oh yay
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday what day is it the crab
feast without a hat oh let's try to kill
you a little bit of came in late where
is he I know I'm a pro pitch touch come
on great such a [ __ ] great to be here
with you
everybody Jay Larson here Jay Larson
calm be calm Jay Larson comedy across
all social hall social mean not much
going on on my own I'm just glad to be
here on the on the crab feast with you
sickle cell and we got some great shows
coming up the only thing I want to
promote its way out and that's in May
I'll be in Nashville on the 20th with
the lol TBD show at the Wild West Comedy
Festival at zany so come on out to that
and that's it but we got some stuff
going on sickle-cell wants you say
what's up Ryan Sickler on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook Ryan Sickler calm
a couple of shows coming up here we're
very excited April 5th April 5th here in
Los Angeles we were doing a crab feast
stand-up show at The Comedy Store in the
belly room right now confirmed decent
lineup a pretty decent lineup al
Madrigal Thomas Agora Theo von ourselves
we're working on a couple other comics
too tickets are $5 right now that's like
a special yeah $5 to see that show April
5th at the Comedy Store
we also have a live crab feast podcast
at the Hollywood improv on April 19th
and we'll be in Bridgetown in June back
in French town doing a live crab feast
podcast very excited to be back at one
of the best festivals in the country and
any information you need you can get
your tickets all that stuff on my
website and the crab feast calm and
again as we say every Tuesday however
you support this show whether it's
telling your friends about it emailing
us tweeting at a social media buying the
merch using the Amazon parrot on reddit
shared on Facebook all of it you guys I
your age write a letter
yeah the premium episodes you're hitting
us up about there up right now you all
you have to do is click on the premium
app link on the website they're
available for iTunes and 9i
toons users it's all there and you know
what this week we got a really fun yes I
think this week so thank you fee stirs
thank you by the way again you know I
know we said it on episode 200 but again
it's been a pleasure man yeah you know
we didn't even have a chance to really
talk about it it's uh it's animate two
hundred you know I did this interview
the other day and the guy goes how long
have you doing the podcast and I was
like what we just did I turn it I'm like
oh my god it's been like four years yeah
that's insane it's insane and it we just
keep building and we wouldn't be
building if it wasn't for you guys
that's for damn sure
you know I mean you guys make it all
worthwhile so thank you thank you thank
you otherwise we're just two dudes
sitting in a room with a guest yeah as a
great guest I'm stoked stoked about it
let's just get to it ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to the crab feast
mr. Josh wolf everybody and I'm gonna
have both of you guys on my podcast
we've been trying we all have a fairly
normal podcast right here on all things
comedy as well it's been good stuff uh
in our home and all things come yeah I
love this studio it's great it's great
for storytelling okay lights down : hey
matter of fact Ryan I we always parked
on the street we come walk in and we see
Josh coming out of the garage like what
are you doing is like wait you don't
know but like know what I'm like how do
you park in the garage they give you a
spot and goes Matt and I goes oh wait
you pay goes I just tell the guy and we
about an hour
we're like what and the guy goes you
just save that yeah and the guy just
says yeah go ahead yeah every time
you're here yeah I got a try yeah it's
like Jenna yeah that's Jenna I got a try
yeah happy about an hour yeah and he
doesn't even ask why you're here I just
make it sound like he should know who I
am and I'm only gonna be by now many
well okay yeah that's it knowing who you
are why don't you just in case anyone
out there doesn't know you're I want you
tell them a little bit about you and
where they can find you on social media
I plug away I'm a comedian my I'm Josh
wolf comedy on Twitter Instagram just
got snapchat today did you are you doing
that channel I I just I feel like I have
to like I don't understand it how old do
I sound but like my son was like you got
to do the the rabbit filter I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about the
rabbit I don't
and he showed me he was like you can do
a dog filter I don't want to be so
people use them yeah dog or a rabbit
like a picture and then it'll put like a
nose and ears but doing that as I'm a
[ __ ] grown man yeah yeah I want to be
a dog or a rabbit yeah but so and yeah
and comedian Joshua phone snapchat no
Joshua of comedy on three of those and
then comedian Josh wolf calm for tour
dates and [ __ ] like that you know and
listen I will tell you man I you've been
on the road some write a bunch ringing
lunch two years ago I was out there a
little bit and then I dialed back with
the kids do you know that feeling when
you're like oh you're kind of re hitting
a stride here I have felt that on stage
where you're like oh this is a good
[ __ ] hour yeah yeah this hour right
now is really sick right now over this
next hour is you better start that [ __ ]
now okay yeah you hit I hit this job
I've started telling a couple of Jody's
stories on stage because it's from
podcasts that I do like a large part of
my crowd now knows who he is yeah it's
very interesting to be able to tell that
personal the story about like he's
almost like Paul Bunyan yeah like some
people don't believe he exists right do
you on the mean yeah like there's so
many Joe Diaz stories I've seen the guy
so many times and I swear to you I don't
know if I've ever heard him repeat a
story I mean I'm sure you have but I
mean it hashas like I've seen him like
you know if you've seen him 20 times and
you're every time it's something
different with it
oh that's and every story is just like
Jesus Christ every way so you go back to
where with him how did you get in the
comedy scene you met okay so I was
living in Seattle
the first time I met him that's not
where you're from is no I'm from
Massachusetts but you were a Seattle
start yeah yeah because you know what I
when I looked at Boston in New York in
LA I was like why am I gonna compete
with the best four five or seven minutes
of stage time when Seattle was offering
15 minutes
there was no five-minute sets it was all
15 no that you just did some research
yeah did you know
why didn't you know what I did yeah I
saved money I moved to LA I didn't know
a thing I didn't know where I would live
I didn't know where I get furniture I
didn't know anything hear me that we
lived in a deep end like a man but
whatever Seattle's our I mean what
listen I mean yeah I mean I jumped in
like a man and you know both of us are
doing pretty well yeah but yeah when I
went up there they were given 15 minutes
at a time which made you be like cuz
when you start you don't go [ __ ] big
I don't get that sometimes well I will
tell you what so I started with Joey
Diaz I started with Brody Stevens a lot
of great Seattle comedians the best
broken story of all time okay so we're
at an open mic roadie
we're exact but he wasn't that guy where
I don't know Mike his name is Steve
Brody that's his real Stephen Brody
Stephen but his real name is just seeing
Brody yes yes
oh the Stephens is an yeah now he goes
by Stephen Brody Stephens so he goes he
was Stephen Brody and he gets off stage
one night and he walks up to me and he
goes oh Steve Brody isn't funny and I go
he's talking about himself now I know I
go he stepped outside of Steve Brody I
said [ __ ] about yeah so I was like why
do you say that man I think you're funny
he goes now Steve Brody isn't funny but
do you know who is I go who he goes
Brody Stephens I go who's that he goes
you'll see you tomorrow
and she got up you were there for the
birth of Brody's been that guy ever
since Wow he never went back to Steve
Brody not in name but in like entire
embodiment he was like and the next
night he came down as this different
dude and I was like that's an
interesting Karen fast but yeah I and I
sold I told Matt for the show I'm like
that's a good character he's like and he
didn't break character he's like I don't
get the whole I don't know if you're
talking about I'm Brody and I was like
and he never went back why never [ __ ]
isn't that core that's like amazing or
crazy depending
I think we know it but it wasn't and um
Joe Diaz when he showed up in town he
was couldn't have been worse he that's
funny yeah it's funny that he's Joe Diaz
then because most people younger go with
the Joey and as they get older yeah they
go to Joe run backwards I don't know
yeah I guess I just knew him us Joe up
then but when he was like he was like no
more than 205 pounds at the time and he
wore a three-piece suit on stage and he
would pace like a madman and it always
he them how old is he now he's like an
Asian guy how you can't really tell how
old he is he could be 60
he could be 35 I have no idea how are
you but he would get on stage and the
best thing about him right is that he
was his first four minutes five minutes
he would [ __ ] tank because he would
try to write jokes and his jokes were
terrible but as soon as he got mad and
just started going off he would crush
and he would be like I got a guy I got a
right better jokes I'm like no you have
to stop and here is the far left I
actually hired him I had a bar
I owned a part of a bar up there and I
hired him I go you need a job and he
goes yeah and I hired him and he was
working the door for me one night we had
a fetish night there on Tuesday nights
what kind of bar it was uh we just
thought up stand-up shows in it no no no
no like if you got a fetish now you
don't have a comedy night no I want to
double up on that no because I didn't
want tommix our [ __ ] I don't [ __ ]
deal with that true yeah babysit those
morons so I hired Joe and there are
these two old what fetish night is it
fetish they come in at what night is
this one do you remember no no no that
it was all fetishes oh it wasn't like
foot fetish night
no like downstairs in the room you had
to pay and to get into there was a table
a glass table that guys would lay under
and look up and watch girls take a [ __ ]
in the bar that was in private room in
their private room and dudes would jerk
off as they were watching girls and I
could see everything through the two-way
glass what if you just showed up cuz
you're in two feet and also this
no so that room was like the wax [ __ ]
you know the relax isn't there to whack
if you wanted to get shocked first of
all how can this be anything else any
other night of the week no I didn't mean
like hey come in for happy hour Monday's
now I think I'm gonna wait for the [ __ ]
bingo on three
it was an upstairs downstairs so the
downstairs was it like a basement and
the basement had a little separate room
and they did the wax and the [ __ ] and
and the shocking wax on yeah they were
shocked you know they like that yeah but
so and with if you were just walking
around it was just different kind of
fetishes right whatever guys dressing
you know women's clothing but the first
night I hired Joey to come in I'm here
with action figures of all they said all
fetish
yeah it was like it was weird but it was
the night I looked forward to the most
every way sure yeah well because he
hip-hop night and rock and roll night
and disco that was boring
well fetish that came our DJ showed up
in a in a hearse he pulled it was his
car it was his car he was insane - but
so Joey the first night he said these
two old dudes probably mid-50s 60 so
could have in Joey's age you know yeah
so they start to yell at each other and
they're dressed in like 1920s like head
to toe you know buttoned up out of wide
dresses and they have little camp
oh dude let's dress and dresses yeah
okay those umbrellas called camisoles
yes they are yeah so they both have the
camisoles - right and so they're yelling
each other and I go Joey you got to get
them out of here and he's like okay and
he was come on YouTube
we gotta get out of here and he grabs
him and they start hitting with the
camisole you let go you stop it you're
not going us he's laughing hysterically
he's like ha ha ha ha come on come on
and laughing they're beating him with a
camisole and walk out and I go um Joe so
I like the controller you used he goes
oh those two old Queens yeah that was
funny I've never been hit with an
umbrella before and I go oh yeah I go
that's great he goes uh he goes but
anybody else besides an old dude in a
dress touches me I'm a [ __ ] knock him
out but I love it if you like he tase
one two years ago yeah that's it that's
now [ __ ] inmate um I'm gonna be on that
glass table oh let me tell you that
glass table was oh who cleaned it out
thank you well it was on it was on
plastic so [ __ ] and wrap it up and then
the next person who replies yeah eerie
plastic and listen there are only so
many girls willing to do it and they
only have so much [ __ ] yeah so I mean I
know that sounds really terrible but you
know they would end this one girl
she wouldn't poop for like two or three
days and then so she had so she was like
I got a strategy I'm like I got it here
like you dies just to get it out yeah
yeah I mean well person well because she
got paid because she had the most right
she could get paid the most wait hold on
I think I ain't by the path quality is
what you're saying no no no no but
listen most girls only you only get one
[ __ ] in you yeah see you normally mean
one a day yeah you don't want any one a
week son but she would be in tomorrow
she would pinch him off so she would do
she could get like six or seven she
would pinch him off and get like six or
seven
so you she got paid more just by
quantity of the amount of time so yeah
yeah the poop table was great but I will
tell you something there were times when
I would when I would see a dude walk in
I'm like wow he looks normal and as soon
as I go he looks normal like no he's
going to the [ __ ] table yeah anybody
who's dressed normal going straight down
to the [ __ ] table because wax guys you
can kind of tell guys I get burned by
wax and the whips guys you could kind of
tell and the [ __ ] guys they were dressed
like us they'd walk in and be like me
where's the downstairs I'm like go get
chicken blood like yeah so I will tell
you there were times when I walked into
that room and you know the smell of [ __ ]
out of a toilet makes me gag yeah it's
strong yeah you not in water you smell
and it's not in the water you realize oh
I the first guy who made a toilet was
like that's got to be in some water yeah
that's that's terrible that's how bad
something smells when it's underwater
and it still smells oh man that's like
it's underwater and it's still smell
that's terrible so okay so Joey Joey I
worked at this place and the place
changed hands a couple times and it
ended up getting bought by these two
dudes who were
crooked crooked and they hire a longer
part-owner now no okay
they high it could pulled out from under
me because the dude I went on the road
one weekend and the most the guy who
owned OD for 85% of it the guy who gave
me 15% was his Japanese dude I told him
I was like a min whatever you do when
you're gone when I'm gone keep the [ __ ]
table night but he put flyers on
anything and yeah he put flyers up at
the u-dub campus it said all ages come
man well so the alcohol bureau came and
shut us down by the time I got back and
so what changed hands whatever so these
crooks buy it and they were like will
you manage it you know this building I
go yeah and so I'm working there for two
months as they're starting and getting
off the ground oh no we're gonna pay you
we're gonna pay one of those we're gonna
pay you we're gonna get you you're still
making money bartender right we're gonna
pay you don't you're you salary so I'm
three months four months in they didn't
pay me and I think the statute of
limitations are out and so the dude one
of the dudes was sold coke in the
basement he was [ __ ] with a waitress
a lot of [ __ ] going on down that basic
yeah he was it was this place was a big
big upstairs downstairs pretty big and
so he was [ __ ] on the waitresses and I
lied to his wife for him all the time
this dude was a scumbag and the other
guy was just an old drunk and he was uh
he owned the old company underground a
guy named swanee okay um so but they
were pay me so I told Joey I'm like hey
when baseball is here when the Yankees
are here on Sunday Friday Saturday
Sunday because I can't go to Bank on
Sunday there's gonna be 35 40 thousands
it's the town I go there's gonna be 35
now he's gonna be 35 $40,000 in that
safe and he was like okay I go here's
what we're gonna do I'm gonna give you
the key to the back you're gonna open
the lock but then you're gonna make it
look like somebody broke it in however
you do that he's like I got that no
problem yeah
Edie you have this back wait was this
book after Colorado Fran
yes okay yes cuz he was he was all over
Colorado oh yeah he still is kidnapping
charges against yeah okay so he's like I
got that no problem I go okay by the way
and here's the type of dude Joe Diaz is
when he would say listen if we get
busted
don't worry about anything I'm not gonna
say anything I go why I'm half of it and
he would say this is like why and I've
told you he babysat my kids and this is
why people love Joey because he said to
me hey Josh wolf you got a family
right you got family got a mother your
father I go yeah and he goes there's
somebody who's gonna miss you I go yeah
he was like nobody's gonna miss me if I
go to jail
there's no way in the world you take a
repres like that's the kind of guy he's
just got that code with his friends
which why people always ask why people
why are they so a lawyer to Joey because
he has um if he likes you
he's in Chania I talked to him today he
is he checked up on while I was gone to
all that crazy [ __ ] I was going through
and stuff yeah he's great he's in a
hundred percent so but we're talking and
he's like all right and I he goes
where's the safe and I tell him I go
there's gonna be forty thousand dollars
in that safe and he was like I can't
[ __ ] wait sound like it was safe we
talking like I mean it's a safe up in
the office where you go need money after
me yeah like one it's got the [ __ ]
price is right we know it was heaviest
[ __ ] yeah so he walks up the stairs goes
in the office now the stairs leading up
were wooden stairs when I come back okay
I get a message somebody broke into the
place you guys had to come down I come
back and I look at the stairs oh so wait
you tell him what you laid out the plan
and then you bounced and he was
executing everything man was cuz if I'm
out of town I'm not a suspect who else
could it be
I was on the road doing standing not me
right so he when he steals it he'd your
hosts what's the combination and I go um
I thought you said you can break into
the safe he goes I can't break into a
[ __ ] safe I go you can't break any
safety goes no well me you gotta go you
said I can break into the safe
and he goes I didn't mean I could break
into the actual safe I meant I could get
the safe I'm like that's two different
things dude that is two completely
differently yeah you're using the
English language incorrectly again
because I understood the words coming
out of your mouth you have to say the
words you mean he was like well you sure
know what I meant I don't know anyway so
he was like how am I gonna get it I go
I'll I'll figure out the combination so
with through some trial and error I
figure out the combination he does a
little [ __ ] Jimmy with a rock or a
hammer or whatever and what you have the
safe we have the safe where does where'd
he meet you with wait I'm out of town he
pushes it down the stalls so he has he
pushes it down the stairs stairs it hits
one stair and goes right through all it
broke through yeah it's a wooden stair
it's like a 200 pound another [ __ ] Tim
yeah so he finally gets it out the funny
thing is it was in an alley right he's
bringing the safe into the car in a
night day like broad [ __ ] daylight in
there he said when he walked out there
were cops down at the end of the alley
and he looked down there and he said he
just gave a quick little wave and they
waved back that's not a fellowship yeah
and he was like listen if I ask it
suspicious they're coming to get me yeah
I waved him he's probably in a
three-piece suit yeah
so he's like Joshua fight and he's
telling me about all this is I can't
[ __ ] wait am I do you have no idea
what I'm doing this [ __ ] my idea book
how much was his [ __ ] gonna be 5050 oh
yeah 55th okay so he calls me and he's
like what the [ __ ] I go what he goes you
wanna know why this [ __ ] safe was so
heavy I go why he goes $28 and quarters
had taken stolen from his own safe he's
stolen from his own sighs oh man he had
beat us to it
[ __ ] 28 and then he goes and you know
what I go what he goes I'm taking all
[ __ ] 28 dollars and I was like okay
you deserve the 20 buck it right it's
what he does but the next day when I saw
him we were out at coffee shop two
papers coffee with quarters that were
sold
yeah dude he and I am oh yeah he was not
happy
it is not I'm not happy oh he you know I
was with him the first time
well I gave him his first hit of ecstasy
and then he went to his yeah he was he
was dating this girl a time and she had
a restraining order against him so they
weren't really date yeah wait they were
dating yeah that was his girlfriend and
she still had the restraining order
yeah she yeah it was all file yeah yeah
but look unless it was necessary but
they still [ __ ] right right so that's
a list so I he grey or he was lucky he
was a gay you got that some that ecstasy
I go out and get some he's like okay she
didn't want to go but I'm not gonna give
her name I'm gonna go [ __ ] what's her
name today like okay so what's her name
had told her neighbors that if you see
this guy last time he was there you see
this guy you call the cops so they get
into the room they start to go at it and
there's a knock at the door and so Carol
doesn't get it and it's none knock at
the door and I just said her name and
yeah and so he goes here police so she
said call [ __ ] so she gets up to answer
the door and comes back in with the
police and what she told me
it said I walked back into the room and
it looked like the mattress was
breathing because he had slipped
he had slipped under the bed but his
stomach was having the mattress go and
then Joe said they cuffed him and that
the first time he ever started to roll
on he he was in the back of a cop car oh
that's when I hit him coughed oh said he
kind of leaned up against the the screen
like hey guys listen that's the greatest
[ __ ] car yeah I've ever had and I
know you're not supposed to with anybody
got any gum a lollipop
yeah I mean this a man that he's got the
best lights on just one you mind if I go
in the back of this he's got amazing
story but like I'm telling you like you
said like check in with you yeah when
things are bad he is a guy that you can
go amen
can you be here yeah be like [ __ ] yeah
so then how did he get into star babies
interview well because you know I was
making between a thousand and eleven
hundred dollars a month and I was
raising three kids by myself her
babysittin budget yeah he was free that
was the budget he would say hey I'll
come over but I get to eat and I was
like okay that's the deal you can eat
but I you know on a thousand dollars a
month there wasn't a whole lot to [ __ ]
I'd be like bread yeah well you know
what our mainstay was then this sounds
gross but the three things that we ate
all the time we're black beans tuna fish
and cheddar cheese all in one
contraption like a bowl yeah we mix it
together put tomato sauce on there rice
tuna fish and hot and like sesame oil
and like anything that I could make in
big you know we used to steal okay
my kids and I we would go into Ralph's
which is the grocery store Hyder and I
could afford one meal a day
crowds [ __ ] yeah I could have waited it
were you getting food stamps or anything
like that yeah you know I did I was on
WIC for a little bit
that was a humbling experience man that
was a real why Pete the way people look
at why yes because I've seen you know i
yeah yeah yes the way people look at you
and the way you feel about yourself yeah
do you mean yeah a lot of people you
know you know I'm I know I have family
who've been on them and like you're that
person at the grocery line cuz they have
to do every one of them individually and
your holds all line up and yeah and I
would go to rouse at 3:00 in the morning
because I avoid I had been there at noon
and bumped into somebody I knew
yeah and it was humiliating dude look as
a grown man you don't feel like running
out of a grocery store crying to a
[ __ ] got the got my to go over
so that was that man that was I did
something I don't think I've ever said
out loud before but yeah I that was the
hardest part for me man is being in that
line and seeing somebody I knew and it
wasn't just seeing them it was seeing
the look on their face of pity and I
never [ __ ] won at anybody's pity I
mean yeah man that's the worst thing I
want I can't compare these two
experiences but the feeling is the same
we when we grew up we had we weren't you
know we didn't have a ton of money we
got the free lunch yeah and we had to go
in the morning before school started to
get the ticket it was a green like you
know like a raffle ticket and you would
go through the line and when you would
pay with that I just remember feeling
like just like oh all and you've seen
these kids every day so they know and
you know when you go and get your ticket
in the morning you see those kids and
you know who those kids are and you're
like man I'm lumped in with that group
over there yeah but listen it is the
same feeling because they're looking at
you the same every day it was really
rough and they were like there was one
time in line where I was paying and then
there a woman behind me offered to pay
for everything and I said no and she was
like I'm I need to get the [ __ ] out of
here no she was she was like let me pay
for this and I was like I can't do that
and she was like let me pay for it I go
I can't take you I can't take your pity
mm-hmm I can't I know you the way you
looked at me when you saw me pan and you
see the kids in the cart and I can't I
couldn't do it and so that was a but we
found ways around the system as you know
everyone does yeah what so I could
afford really one meal a day for all of
us so we wouldn't bulk we would go to
Ralph's and one meal a day we would go
to hot food section and it was this rock
and roll Ralph's up there on right and
the woman behind the counter newest
after the first week we went at the same
time every day the kids would pick out
the meal and then I would put them in
the cart and then I would pretend that I
was a tour guide and I would give them a
tour
walking tour of the Ralph's while they
ate and so in the lady behind the
counter finally caught on to it but she
didn't care but I remember once my
oldest son we're walking out he goes I
just want to make sure like we're not
stealing right and I go no no no I go
you got anything in your pocket and he
goes no I go where is everything he goes
my stomach I go by the nuts yours if
it's in your stomach it's it's yours
ya can't argue with that
I also you know when you're poor you
have to invent ways to entertain your
kids and my kids used to love it when I
would I had a Saturn for a while and
they used to love it when I would put
him in the trunk and drive around in
empty parking lots and you could hear
him tumbling around on each other they
fight blows was it close the other
clothes on no was the clothes and
clothes yes both both clothes thing
clothes yeah when you were like close I
didn't want to I was like I couldn't
hurt him right and you said it again I
was like yeah yeah yeah get in the trunk
naked we're gonna drive around on their
own so they used to love it and going
over speed bumps and they'd that's what
this there's and I remember walking out
a rouse once after we had already stolen
our lunch and we're walking out and as
we're getting to my car my daughter goes
hey Dad can you put us in the trunk
again as a cop is walking back
she's so funny but like they loved that
game saying I want to knock that rice
ball ready we would my mom would just
take us a mystery rides that was her
whole thing because it was just my mom
with the four of us and we didn't have
any money so she would just drive around
this big green Chevy she had all four of
us and we're like where we going on a
mystery ride and then just come to find
out we were just driving around
neighborhoods
yeah which now I love it but with
clothes now we're on clothes but there
was this one like this is like shopping
center behind our house down like this
back path and there was this one like
long alley that didn't have any lights
and my mother would start going down and
she turned the lights off in the car and
we drive down and like with no lights on
I thought was the coolest yeah mystery
wrap you know what that just shows you
and you guys have how your kids minor
and a half and two years and one six
months here's what that goes and shows
you and I will tell you it's what I
learned early early on with the kids
especially having no money you know
those especially here people throw those
extravagant parties and all that [ __ ]
that's not what you remember you
remember the mystery ride yeah like you
remember the things that I'll never take
I had no you remember that saying that
you're that whatever creative thing that
your parents did that's why I like at it
very young I never bought into the you
know out here they do [ __ ] goody bags
so if you go to somebody's birthday
usually I remember I never did goody
bags and one kid was like where's my
what's my goodie bag I was like it's the
it's your stomach you have a key of cake
right so like me you're leaving with
cake there you go like and parents were
like you gotta have a goodie bag I'm
like no I [ __ ] don't
yeah yeah I don't like and I don't have
to this is my kids party yeah you bring
the [ __ ] goodie bag and give it to my
son but I never did any of that huge
extravagant bounce houses and all that
stuff oh you put in here a single dad
with three kids [ __ ] affording that not
me yeah no we stole [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah but hiring more hire and Joey
having him babysit was like hey well
done at what age was your oldest that
you were like I can leave them all under
they're the oldest supervision
umm-hmm well you know is young you know
it's gonna be young no no was it no no
no because I trusted my daughter more oh
and what's the age difference a year and
a half okay but I trusted her more but
he wouldn't listen to her and you know
my oldest was always a little bit like
[ __ ] these two I didn't really trust to
leave him alone like we couldn't decide
the joke growing up was you know we
would be like I can't decide if he's
gonna play triangle in the band or kill
70 people yeah we were always we
couldn't dealt like and the joke would
be like if we'd seem to one thing I'm
like there's your triangle and then we'd
see the next thing I'm like oh he's
gonna [ __ ] kill a cat yeah do you
know so um but but what Joey was like
when he babysat the kids it was the best
they loved Joe Diaz night more than
anything in the world one because I'm
sure anything went it was their fetish
night yeah exactly what time would they
go to bed with him well that's the thing
like he imagined him renew like Ken's
asleep they're still up no but I will
tell you he okay
the kids loved because innately they
kind of knew like I knew them look he
was definitely not he an orthodontic he
was a little unorthodox but he would
have taken a bullet to the kids and at
at my price range that's all I could ask
for
right yeah keep him safe yeah I've told
you before but you know my daughter's
favorite game to play with him was when
he bent over he never wore underwear
when he bent over in front of her she
would rip ass hair out of the crack of
his ass I remember she did that one I
was brave I was walking in she had
ripped hair out of the VA's ass crack
and she goes how many and he was all
felt like five
that time like that implies that that
games been played a bunch of title while
she and then the worst part is she just
kind of sprinkled the hair on the ground
what's happening mom what the [ __ ] is
happening in a girl a good what they're
safe when I had zero zero money right
and you guys know how expensive daycares
I had to learn how to pay for make money
without with the kids with me I started
my I started my own peanut butter and
jelly delivery service did you really
yeah wait it was called PB and J's we we
did leave man that's creative it's
called a PB and J's I'm way he was proud
of me face light up no I wasn't proud of
anything in Jerry I mean we did listen
we got who you delivering yeah we got
shut down by the Health Department out
no PBJs out of a sadder
it was there were some things I didn't
think all the way through I will admit
the name broccoli all will yeah we're
broccoli all wheels that this is
Brigadier Brock we could say anything
yeah you know I have never thought about
how evering - yeah who are your
customers okay how did you get them
alright so this was pre-internet I'm
assumed free internet pre cell phone
just pager okay okay had a home phone in
a pager right so we made up menus I
found one in my garage last week that's
the menu yeah you got to send us a
picture of it yeah if you find it okay
put a sentence a picture also so and I
made peanut butter and fluff and I sold
yoo-hoos and people didn't know what
fluff was oh yeah that's the [ __ ] that's
right Lisa great substitute honey tastes
just like it we did honey we did fluff
we did nutella we did the whole thing we
do you were like a food truck before
yeah you were yeah except we were in a
sweaty ass Saturn no air conditioning my
Saturn had no air conditioning we also
had a st. Bernard deliver to the house
I'd say that so delivered to the house
no we had one who lived at the house oh
my dog so the same the crazy thing is
like so with the Saturn had no air
conditioning but the dog also came with
us so that you know st. Bernard shed a
lot so the basically when it was hot
here were your options but you're hot
you put the dog in the front and the
kids in the trunk what no no no the kids
would sit in the backseat my dog was in
the front seat cuz he was too big to sit
in the backseat with them it was a
Saturn so dog goes looking balanced head
out the window and then I would look and
then I would look in inevitably who was
ever sitting behind him
at his drool like yeah flattered all
over last days okay but when you sat in
that satyr and here are your two choices
windows up no air conditioning windows
up
you could get whatever was coming out it
was hot air but you sweat like it was
like a [ __ ] sauna or windows down you
know what it was but yeah windows down
it was cooler but there was so much st.
Bernard hair in there you walked out and
you look like a [ __ ] wookie yeah you
sweat a little bit so it's stuck did you
even have car seats
I had one car seat yeah one well the six
and four oh yeah at that point and so
okay so here's what would happen we got
a bunch of menus we walked up and down
Hollywood Boulevard just places that
were close to the house that I knew when
someone paged me I could get there we
walked up and down all of you were
Boober eats exactly and we walked up and
down and handed out the menus up and
down every floor of every [ __ ] you
know yeah on Hollywood and Wow what else
are we gonna do
so may I probably things oh yeah don't
worry dad's got this hand yeah the kids
are like we got everything
temperate just temperate always telling
you who's new we're not making merch
till we lock March would have been a
great idea man
well here was the better idea right so I
figured out very early on that when I
delivered the food I didn't get any tips
but when the three kids delivered the
food oh yeah so I got a little red wagon
and you liked those parents in India
that puts the kid out in the street we
know here's I would mess up their hair I
would like rip a shirt a little bit are
you pleading yeah I was just I was not
that far away from smearing here's a
little dirt get in there and we work
together so they would whatever the bill
was they would basically get that in tip
also so it was great so but it was hard
we started to get really popular because
I like where were you getting customers
just from that handouts and stuff that
would that they're on the menu in
word-of-mouth at these three people do
love the PB&J but you know
want to buy the peanut butter jelly in
the bread just to have around the house
because you just like its splurge huh
right so the an entire they knew the
three kids were coming and they get the
office would do it every office would do
it once a month but I had 30 offices
20th Century Fox one night did a
showcase at the improv and I made two
hundred and fifty peanut butter and
jelly it was the last thing I made I
couldn't smell peanut butter for like
that what was your profit margin on that
well you gotta figure I was selling each
sandwich and everything for like 750
really yeah
holy [ __ ] well here's what I would do I
would put it in a brown paper bag and
then I would write a note from your mom
so it was up to you if you wanted your
mom these kids even have a mom now but I
would write that I was writing jokes so
depending if you wanted your mom to be
nice good luck in school today or you
know you could go from nice mild to hot
and hot with things like your dad's
moving out but I've always thought you
were cute meet me meet me later I've got
some whatever you know I would just
write stupid [ __ ] and so people like the
novelty of it and they like the kids
coming in so we started get too busy I
couldn't wait to busy we were getting
busy but then there's franchise there's
the door there's a knock at the door
right and I'm in the I'm in the kitchen
and I tell my oldest son hey can you get
that he's like yeah when I hear my son
go it's for you
I turn the corner out of the kitchen
shirtless I got peanut butter all over
my chest in my hand fresh out of the
trunk problem yeah and there's a guy at
the front door holding a clipboard and
he goes this is PB and J's and I said
I'm sorry we only do tail what do you
want Chuck you really do take out we
don't dine it yeah and he goes oh I know
that he goes I'm with the Health Board
and he turned his clipboard around now
I'm shirtless my kids are on the floor
on a blanket like putting sandwiches
together yeah the same with st. Bernard
is next time the st. Bernard hair all
over the place so they're putting
sandwiches together on the floor
watching Blue's Clues like a like a
Kathie Lee Gifford factory just little
Asian kids like
together right and and I'm sitting there
shirtless and the guy was like he goes
this is wrong I go which party goes all
of it it's all wrong with five and I go
the name price ed I go all put a shirt
on he goes the shirt isn't the problem
because you have a st. Bernard next to
your food workers who are how old are
you son and he said to my oldest son I
like I don't answer that
and he goes seven seven he goes your
oldest worker is seven and I was like
he's my son we're doing this and I
explained it to him he goes listen you
got to shut this down like right now but
give me a peanut butter right now and I
said I got to take this delivery on and
he was like if you take this delivery
out and I find out you took it out we're
gonna find you really yeah how much were
we talking here what seems that can get
pretty stiff yeah but I was like hey I'm
making peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches in my living room good luck
getting some money yeah great good
[ __ ] luck this is how I'm paying
yeah yeah we did that I guess we
probably did that for like three and a
half months maybe four months I mean
good money let's swing 250 Sam under 7
that was on the table got ya got too big
went on Shark Tank what else something
no listen it wasn't that big except when
you're working one man and a pager
yeah it's you know if you want people
paid you then you call him back I'd call
back and ask what the order was yeah
yeah yeah yeah number one my number one
seller was peanut butter and fluff with
a yoohoo and chocolate chip cookie
really I didn't sides well yeah I had a
lot of listen I worked this you know the
remember the Otis Spunkmeyer comes
course I remember Otis so there was a
girl in my acting class and she was a an
Otis Spunkmeyer rep and so I was like
hey do you get sell of that name my
friend the night me too we used to make
fun we used to do the Arsenio Hall voice
and introduce him like Otis
oh yeah that's a great name what were
they I never and they were like the East
Coast version of mrs. fields they were
yes that was his name Oh delicious Meyer
they were great what a terrible name it
was terrible name
because Spunkmeyer you did he's yeah I
hate I'm I'm saying growing up we didn't
have him no no I I only heard of him out
here terrible name
but so she was the rep another company
with a shitty Spunkmeyer
because spunk where I grew up meant kind
of course everywhere yeah so Otis
Spunkmeyer I was like just do it needs
to rethink its PB&J sounds like a great
name compare yeah you know but then as
soon as you have that cookie like those
cookies we're getting a rare hey man
where's the spunk my room is that
downstairs yeah table try some cookies I
just opposed tell you are you telling me
if I told you a there's a [ __ ] room
downstairs you wouldn't go downstairs
take a look I definitely would go down
and check be cured I'd have to know was
good yeah there's no way I could not
that's all I'm saying and that was one
of the things some people paid cover
they weren't they just wanted to look
through the window and be like so that
dude is but to get and I'd be like yeah
he's gonna like it's a glass table and
he likes to see poop come out of her ass
oh I saw that it on a Geraldo episode
one time no lie that really civically
like fetishes and that was one eat they
talked about they didn't do it what
happens in your life
wait where because because what I'm it
has to happen the first time where you
see it do you not I mean yeah but like
when is the first time you see it by
accident
that's the calling man you think you
just I don't know I used to date a girl
she and she told me that her fresh
English she had a best friend who had
been with a guy for a long time and they
they got big as a couple got to that
point where he would put saran wrap on
his face you know she would just poop on
that is and to come on and that makes
two really fucked-up decisions yeah I've
never wanted anyone to pee on me I've
never wanted to hit on anybody else
does not I really peed on the girl in
the shower one time she wanted and
showers like I'll pee on your leg but
that was it and how is the kid around
with Kate about it okay well how did
that make you feel like did you want to
[ __ ] her like that yeah man it didn't it
didn't it didn't turn me off and it
didn't turn me on I just felt like I was
peeing on somebody you know what I mean
like I'm pig on a tree it was no yeah
she wasn't like oh my god yeah she was
just like oh you just peed on my leg I
was like he asked me to pee on your leg
yeah but here's deal like my brain goes
to this if if I peed on her leg
what other nasty [ __ ] has somebody done
to this girl and not now I'm gonna do
you know what do you know what the only
time anyone's ever told me anything that
made me rethink going out with them I
had been dating dating from my ex for
about six months and she was she said we
were talking and she was like but it's
like that time I [ __ ] Shawn Kemp I go
what oh my god I said what she was here
she goes I didn't tell you I had sex
with Shawn Kemp I go no she goes with
that it mattered I like yeah he's got 46
he yeah yeah and probably a 74 inch day
yeah easily like so yeah that's like a
little heads up about [ __ ] Shawn Kemp
would have been that's the only time I
but if somebody said to me yeah I let
tell me [ __ ] on me before I be like mmm
I had a girl that wanted to give me a
head while I took a dump and I that was
the end of it I ended that right there I
don't know if I could get hard
I mean look I've I've said this before
and I'm you know when you mentally
really break it down you think about it
the the sucking and the pushing probably
it probably is an amazing [ __ ]
feeling but I was like I don't think
you're taking in consideration one the
smell you know it's in water it's
possible splash back yeah possible
splash back and it's just [ __ ] I
don't want to touch you see you nothing
after that that's the grossest [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was easy to end that one yet
wait but the push in the suck I don't
think I think he's just trying to help
her out with that okay if you are if
you're blowing out both ends so to speak
that probably feels pretty think of us
if you sneezed and farted every single
to hold ah maybe it what amazed just
threw a sneeze into them
yeah yeah that's the truck Thanks now
that I'm into if you could just throw a
little pepper up Minaj get the [ __ ] out
of here that felt amazing did you have
the website it got taken down to my
favorite websites cake farts one of my
favorite you've seen you don't put cake
in their ass crack and fart if you've
never seen cake fart OH oh my god it's
the funniest thing you've ever seen your
life but there was also one called fart
hammer fart hammer was the dude would
get blown and then he'd come in
someone's mouth but he would make her
leave her mouth oh come on that's real
cake farts is one of my favorite things
there's there's a close-up you got it
like a cake farts you have to it's it's
I hope it's still up it's maybe the best
thing you'll ever see in your life cake
for Oh sounds like a game changer we
kind of I don't know exactly how we got
on this but I apologize you took us
there um my pond did you do any bananas
in any of those PB and J's yeah people
asked for him it was on the menu so you
got shut down like down yeah I got shut
down like I listen we we had a lot of
there were more there was slave labor
yeah [ __ ] paying them nothing not
well they get paid labor I got in
trouble in weird ways okay
okay once I you know I used when we when
I first threw my axe out as much as I we
needed to split up it was also like
horribly frightening for me like I and
I'm not a big drinker but I would end up
in my kitchen just drunk you know
sobbing because I'm like I'm never gonna
be able to do anything that I ever want
to do because I don't how am i I just
have to do this first then I am making
care of the kids yeah making $1,000 a
month like that's not gonna cut it like
in so hard to be creative like it was
hard
made all that stuff and there was one
time my brother and I were in the
kitchen we were drinking and I was
packing their lunches kids lunches and
as a joke I was like wouldn't that be
funny and I put a can of Budweiser in my
son's scooby-doo lunchbox I'm like aah
so we wake up next day we drive everyone
to school and I go back I'm a little
hungover and I go back to the house and
about 11:00 I got a phone call he was
Jacob was going to the Jew school at the
time
temple Israel sorry yeah that good juju
yeah so um and so I get a call hey mr.
wolf we need to come in and make sure
and I get in there and the rabbi wants
to see him like let's corner I guess sit
down and I'm you know at the time he was
having a little problem with touching
people and being a little aggressive the
rabbi yes you know he'd like to grab
dicks oh no no no my son well having
[ __ ] out so I thought that's what it
was right and I go what's going on he
was like and he had Jacobs lunchbox and
I go what's going on d you guys you
didn't want to mean lunch today and the
rabbi just turned lunchbox around
opened it up and the can of Budweiser
was still in there and I was like he
didn't finish it yeah because I was
drunk I forgot to I was like I'll take
it out and he was like what's this and I
was like all right here's the truth and
I told him I was drunk and I thought I'd
be funny I was drunk I thought it'd be
funny if he showed up you know I was
making jokes with my brother because I
thought I'm just gonna be honest and
he's a dude and he's gonna be like
totally get it right yeah just take the
can and get out of here you rascal man
nope the rabbi great sense humor he was
like he was like your son can get thrown
out of school for this I'm like well he
didn't drink it that was my defense Yeah
right I was like look if you really want
to do this it's not open so this not
really against the law and he was like I
think it is I was like I don't think it
and he was like we could throw you out
I'm like give it a shot you know what
halls like man I got the the Board of
Health quick we used to go to us there
was a strip club
vii fails near that yeah we used to go
down there me and a couple of guys and
the afternoon strippers were like it's a
different there was one time the a woman
called D calls and the beat
yeah the B Squad we heard one girl when
she was walking around the corner and
then she turned around she goes oh wait
wait a second baby mommy needs to work
so her kid clearly was backstage trying
to follow her out on stage and that's
when I was like I can't come back like
this [ __ ] yeah be a [ __ ] real parent
that make some freebie be OJ's for
Christ's sake yeah got a menu right here
yeah man we was a it was I will tell you
this um having the kids and going
through that made me a better comic
because one night I got on stage and
could not stop the emotion right I
couldn't stop the reality so you know
when were younger you write jokes cuz
you think other people will think
they're funny right sure and you're but
I could not stop the reality because it
was just bubbling up and it was the only
place for me to get it out there so I
told a real story and [ __ ] that I'd
always been scared about talking about
in that way with my kids and it hit
better than it an't in a way that none
of my jokes had never told before hit
because it had honesty in reality and
emotion in with a joke and I was like oh
[ __ ] and it changed everything from that
second I was like oh like this is how
you're supposed to do it you're supposed
to have a certain level of honesty and
attachment to whatever I didn't have any
attachment any of my jokes they were
just kind of like oh this is funny I'm
gonna write this joke and that and
what's more vulnerable than a single dad
to three [ __ ] kids was when you're
stealing from Ralph's and [ __ ] yeah man
I remember telling the story about when
my daughter came out she came out of the
bath naked and she had her hands over
her vagina and she goes teddy and now
you know I got no there's no woman there
and she was my squeegee hurts and she
said squeegee so I thought it was cute
yeah I was like oh that's cute baby I
know what's wrong and then she took her
hand off and spread her legs and she
goes I don't know can you look at it I
go no no I can't look at it there's a
mirror on the hip I say if it looks like
this picture
I said no I can't I can't look at it but
I can tell you is you probably need some
powder and she was like okay but she
would always what about when she started
getting her peers what I thought you
were gonna say no when she got her
period luckily I was married and my wife
kind of good yeah they were looked when
they got older it's a whole different
like when you went my son recently I was
what he's 19 right and he's he almost
cut his had his three Coast toes cut off
last week two weeks ago he still might
lose two toes they're black come on whoa
[ __ ] grips but we we're I was walking
into his room come maybe a month ago and
this teenage boys are gross like they're
[ __ ] when you open that door it smells
like he's been baking feet in there and
like a warm wave of you're like yeah so
I'm walking to his bed and I'm like hey
man and he stops me go I go what he
don't step on that sock it was in the
shape of like a teepee as I come on how
long has that been there he's like I
don't know I go put it in the hamper he
goes I would yeah it's a whole different
level a newcomers called PBD penis balls
it's some really dumb ridiculous [ __ ]
your clan man a clan you guys were a
clan you know yeah I mean like you know
there's families and you do family stuff
but like you guys were in it together
that's yeah awesome well I will tell you
some I went in in I remember auditioning
for a World Series commercial for Fox
when the kids were young and they at a
very young age but going to my auditions
and just sit there and can sit quietly
how many were you taking we taking all
three or what's one getting old enough
now know the summer time three of them
right huh
so and if so there are were all three in
the audition and I was doing it but they
they kept looking over at the kids
during my audition and they way they're
in they
go into the audition room yeah what are
they gonna do sit out in the [ __ ]
lobby I mean I've been in auditions
where guys will come with their kid be
like hey you guys mind keep an eye on
him like now so when that's nice we're
in the bullpen then they go in you know
but there's three of them like that's a
no that's not you can't do that to
people know and they had learned that
was just one of the things I learned
when we walk in here you guys are quiet
yeah and they just they just learned
that that's what they were doing hand
out some menus and then just get yeah
but they kept looking at the kids and
the guy was gonna stop you here he was
like uh we're not interested in you for
the commercial but we would be
interested in the four of you he said
can they behave like that on set and I
go yeah and he was like done you seem in
a truck yeah yeah yeah they're great
are you stick him in a trunk they will
shut up whatever you want yeah clothes
or no clothes doesn't matter
so wait did you guys book it yeah the
two youngest ones ended up not wanting
to do it so it's just makeup recast yeah
but you know I actually I remember one
time one of my development deals I was
at NBC and we ran NBC and the guy NBC
turns me goes so who do you see playing
Josh and I was like uh me Josh let me go
really and I was like no that's not good
it's some people forget cuz we have Ryan
I have mutual friends that have gotten
deals and they're like it's in the deal
it's not in it that they will be in it
and I and I've had deals where that's
never I've until it gets they're gonna
make a pilot there's no guarantee that
you're gonna be in it at all it's like
we had a friend that was just getting
pissed I can't believe they don't want
even like dude that no one no no one
gets it but it's a shock when you're
Josh oh yeah yeah yeah I remember
writing a script with a guy one of the
day there's only one Tony Danza you know
yeah it's true it was playing Tony Tony
Tony that's right that's that Tony
danza's that's me just saying that a
dude's Tony in every Izzy Tony in the
new Sebastian he's in the new Sebastian
Josie
yes dad is he Tony it's a perfect choice
for his dad it's a perfect choice I had
Marilu Henner on my podcast uh-huh and
first of all she's gorgeous she is
gorgeous but you know she has one of
those memories where she remembers every
second of every bit of her life that
sounds like the worst like you don't
want to have that would you want that
memory I don't know I remember way too
much but not every [ __ ] second thank
god no I would not want no she told me
we're like if Sweet Home Alabama comes
on her brain Bri brings up a list of
every time she's ever heard that song in
her life wow that sounds [ __ ] it
oh that sounds can't get off book though
no come on Nardo
oh good reference is one of my favorite
sitcoms of all - absolutely yeah is it
in your top five Oh easy
what taxi yeah man yeah I mean I think
all the greatest sitcoms probably
happened pre-1990 except for Seinfeld
when's Cosby you don't for Cosby ladies
Cosby 80s ladies yeah oh [ __ ] Cosby taxi
Cheers
Night Court was great Night Court was
Oscar good time family it's all in the
family those were 70s I'm gonna say
Three's Company where he's coming in 70s
also yeah wait so yeah I guess so I
don't know do you consider Family Guy a
sitcom the no it's an out anime no it's
animated but I was no rules and
animation isn't that crazy
no animated and it you can say anything
if you're if you're a cartoon or if you
sing you can sing or be a cartoon the
most I were the first family Guidance
yeah puppets can say the first family
guy sauce do we got an accident he falls
down he goes take me to the doctor and
he passes out and he wakes up and he
goes make sure he's not black and he
passes out again another am i watching
oh my god did he just say make sure yeah
um Marilu Henner you got to get out of
here I get you had on the podcast you
were saying oh all right jobs just
saying like on our memory our memory is
like it's something that I don't I don't
think that I would there's so many
things that I don't want to remember
yeah don't you think sound like if what
you've told yeah oh sure this past ow
I'm totally kidding this was [ __ ]
awesome this is a lot of fun thank you
for coming on we got to get out of here
and get you to a flight yeah and you
guys we even we even I didn't get to
tell you about my 10:00 a.m. trip to
strip club in Mexico you're gonna have
to come back and tell the rest of these
right here so thank you for coming on
real quick again social media and then
you get the hell out Josh wolf comedy is
uh Twitter Instagram and now snapchat
you find me there with a dog face and
comedian Joshua for tour dates and if
you want to listen to podcast it's
fairly normal but Josh wolf on all
things company awesome and it's always
always always a pleasure there's a lot
of fun as always Jay Larson commie comm
Jay Larson comedy on all social media
Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram
Facebook Ryan Sickler comm talk to you
all next Tuesday